[موسيقى]
من ينقذ السودان المعارك في شهرها الثالث
ولا افق للحسم هدد هدد متتاليه لم تنجح في
وقف القتال بين الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع واستمرار النزيف اكبر من ان يحتمل
فلم يتبقى في السودان الكثير البنوك نهبت
المواط قتلوا كل المنازل سرقت هناك عنف
غير مبرر وعنف ضد النساء هذا هو الحال كما
وصفه مالك عقار نائب رئيس مجلس السياده
السوداني اما الامين العام للامم المتحده
فقال ان السودان يغرق في الموت والدمار
بسرعه غير مسبوقه وحذر رئيس مفوضيه
الاتحاد الافريقي موسى فكي من امكانيه
انزلاق البلاد الى حرب اهليه وانهيار
الدوله فدائره الصراع تجاوزت الخرطوم وام
درمان وامتدت الى اقليم دافوره المطرب
والى كردفان واتهمت واشنطن قوه الدعم
السريع وحلفائها بارتكاب فضاعات في دارفور
يحدث هذا في يكتسي فيه الصراع ابعادا
اقليميه ودوليه فهناك اتهامات امريكيه
لقوه فاجنر الروسيه بتزويد قوات الدعم
السريع بصواريخ ارض جو كما ان هناك تقارير
عن مشاركه مقاتلين من دول الجوار في
المعارك ضمن قوه الدعم السريع والمحصله
ليست فقط موجات نزوح الى دول الجوار
بالماساه الانسانيه مكتمله الاركان تضاف
الى ماس امتنا مع تحديد برنامج الغذاء
العالمي من ان 40% من السودانيين سيعانون
الجوع اذا استمر القتال لكن كيف اله
الامور الى هذا وكيف بدات المعارك في
قصتنا السودان من ينقذ الدوله نرصد المسار
السياسيه في البلاد منذ عزل الرئيس عمر
البشير قبل اربعه اعوام وكيف تحولت
العلاقه بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع وقائدها محمد حمدان دقلو من الوفاق
الى الخلاف والص على خلفيه جدل حاد على
توحيد المؤسسه العسكريه ودمج الدعم السريع
فيها وصولا الى تفجر المعارك منتصف ابريل
الماضي اما بقيه هذه القصه فنستكملها مع
الدكتور عبد الله علي ابراهيم المفكر
والمؤرخ والاكاديميه السوداني والدكتور
اسماعيل احمد رحمه الباحث القانوني
والمحلل السياسي السوداني نسال ضيفين
الكريمين عن تداعيات استمرار الصراع على
تماسك الدوله السودانيه واحتمالات دخول
اطراف سودانيه اخرى فيه وعن مدى تاثير هذا
الصراع في حال تفاقمه على دول الجوار
السوداني نسال ايضا عن فرص نجاح التحركات
والمبادرات المطروحه لانهاء الصراع لكن
لنشاهد القصه اولا وبعدها الح
[موسيقى]
في وسط السودان يوم الاحد
شكل الحادي عشر من ابريل 2019 بدايه دوره
جديده لانخراط المؤسسه العسكريه في اداره
السودان عقب اعلان وزير الدفاع السوداني
اعوض بن عوف ازاحه الرئيس السوداني السابق
عمر البشير وتشكيل مجلس عسكري انتقالي
برئاسته بعد خمسه ايام من اعتصام متظاهرين
المطالبين بتغيير النظام امام القياده
العامه للقوات المسلحه بعد يوم واحد اعلن
بن عوف تنحيه عن المنصب وتعيين عبد الفتاح
البرهان وفي حين رفض قائد قوات الدعم
السريع محمد حمدان دقلو المشاركه في بن
عوف بحجه دعمه لمطالب الجماهير لكنه سرعان
ما وافق في الثالث عشر من ابريل على
المشاركه في مجلس البرهان اثر ترقيته الى
رتبه فريق اول وتعيينه نائب له ليصبح
الشخص الثاني في المجلس ولتبدا مرحله
جديده بين مكونين عسكريين سيشكل مسارهما
علاقه متشابكه اشعلت شراره حرب لا يزال
دوي رصاصها في سماء الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
تمرر الاعتصام امام مبنى القياده العامه
للجيش السوداني بسبب مطالب الشارع الثوره
السوداني بحكم مدني بخروج المؤسسه
العسكريه بعوده الجيش الى السكلات مطالبون
بان الجنجويد ينحل
الفريق اول محمد حمدان حميد عن السريع
زودت قوات الدعم السريعه الدعم السريه تم
تاسيسه بامر من القاعده الاعلى للقوات
المسلحه
بمهام محدده مهام الدعم السريع اسناد
الجيش بعيدا الدعم السريع بشكل اخر هو جزء
من القوات المسلحه في السودان
المهام التي اوكلت
لدعم السريع حمايه الفصل الجمهوري حمايه
المواقع الاستراتيجيه
ولايه الخرطوم كانت تحت يد
الدعم السري
في الثالث من يونيو فضت قوات عسكريه
اعتصام القياده العامه مخلفه عددا من
القتلى والمفتودين
الجيش
صرح المجلس العسكري بانه لم يصدر اوامر
بالفض بينما قال حميدتي ان الامر فخ نصب
لقواته ما اثار مؤشرا لبدايه خلاف يتشكل
بين الدعم السريع والجيش
كله عرفنا الان شغالين بيت دينه وبرجلنا
عشان نوصل الدوله العمل فينا العمليه دي
حبل المشنقه باذن الله
طبيعه العلاقه بين الجيش والدعم السريع في
فتره فضل الاغتصام كانت على اعلى درجاتها
كان
قائد الدعم السريع جزء من اتخاذ القرار
[موسيقى]
بعد الفضي مباشره اعلن البرهان ايقاف
التفاوض مع قوى الحريه والتغيير التي شرعت
في مظاهرات ضخمه اجبرت المجلس العسكري على
العوده الى طاوله التفاوض حيث قدم رئيس
الوزراء الاثيوبي ابي احمد والاتحاد
الافريقي في يونيو 2019
مقترحا بالعوده الى التفاوض وتشكيل مجلس
سيادي مكون من ثمانيه مدنيين وسبعه
عسكريين
ضمن المجموعه بتاعه الوفد المفاوض للحريه
التغيير وكان في اتجاه من المجلس العسكري
هو الانفراد بالحكم حينها كانوا هم
متوافقين واضح في في النسب وفي التفاوض
انتهت المفاوضات في السابع عشر من اغسطس
2019 الى توقيع اتفاق سياسي اتخذ مسمى
الوثيقه الدستوريه تتضمن الالتزام
بالاعلان الدستوري
اختيار عبد الله حمدوك رئيسا للوزراء انا
عبد الله
[موسيقى]
على الرغم من الاتفاق على حكومه مدنيه ظل
المكون العسكري المتمثل في مجلس السياده
يمارس ادوارا سياسيه مختلفه حيث ترى
ساحميتي قياده مفاوضات السلام في جنوب
السودان واللجنه العليا لاداره الازمات
الاقتصاديه واللجنه العليا لجمع السلاح
بجانب عضويته في مجلس شركاء الفتره
الانتقاليه الادوار السياسيه ما هي يعني
والدعم السريع في في اداره الدوله في صراع
السياسي
[موسيقى]
بدات تزايد المضطرد لنفوذ قوات الدعم
السريع عقب اجتذابه لبعض ضباط الجيش
للخدمه في صفوفه
الرواتب العاليه هي كان السبب في التحاق
الضباط والجنود لكن لا يمكن ان ننسى ان
الجيش او استخباراته لديها درايه الكافيه
بانه يجب ان يقول لديها افراد داخل قوات
الدعم السريع وهذا وضح في حرب 15 ابريل
حرب الخرطوم عندما انسحب اكثر من
ضابط قوات مسلحه كانوا ملتحقين بالدعم
السريع ومع صدور قرار بحل هيئه العمليات
التابعه لجهاز المخابرات والامن في عام
2020 بدات سيطره الدعم السريع على
معسكراتها وعتادها هناك تزمر داخل الجيش
من الدعم السريع وتمدده
وتوسعه الضباط الوطن المسلحه متزمرين كيف
انت تحل يعني هيئه العمليات وتسليبه كل
مواقع هيا طلعت سليمه لحميتها مش للجيش
يعني في هيئه العملات كان في اكثر من
اربعين دبابه استلمها حميدتي وكان تجي
اسلحه ضخمه جدا تحت علم وسمع البرهان وعدم
رضا من القوات المسلحه
لكل واجب من واجبات القوات المسلحه قوات
الدعم السريع كانت حاضره وكانت عندها
كلمته وكان عندها موقفها
قوه شبه موازنه المسلحه كان في غيرها في
الدعم السريع بياخذ اربع اضعاف الجندي في
القوات المسلحه امتيازات واسعه ضباط
امتيازات واسعه
في ظل التجاذبات المكونين العسكريين وتوسع
نفوذهما سعى رئيس الوزراء عبد الله حمدوك
في عام 2020 الى دمج منظومه الجيش
الاقتصادي في المؤسسات المدنيه وسيطره
وزاره الماليه عليها وهو ما رفضه المكون
العسكري
[موسيقى]
121 شركه شركات حكوميه شركات الجيش ما
وجدنا منها الشغال بصوره رسميه اكثر من
200 طلب اشراف وزاره الماليه الكامل على
موارد تصنيع الحربيه خلاف الدعم السريع
والقوات المسلحه برئاسه برهان باعتبار
القائد العام
اعترضوا على التسليم الكامل لكل موارد
بادر فيها اصلاح القطاع الامني والعسكري
والشروع في الوصول لجيش مهني
وقومي ودي مهمه لازم تدعمك وفي يونيو 2001
2021 حاول حمدوك اصلاح القطاع العسكري
والامني من خلال مبادره الطريق الى الامام
لكن رفض الدعم السريع دمج قواته في الجيش
السوداني احدث عقبه في مسار الانتقال
السياسي في البلاد وكانت تلك اولى مظاهر
الخلاف بين الجيش والدعم السريع التي برزت
على السطح والقوات
والدعم السريع حاجه واحده
[موسيقى]
الناس شغاله اشاعات الحكومه الاولى تحديدا
كان المكون العسكري جزء من يعني في شراكه
مع المكون المدني للاسف مرت بمراحل صعبه
جدا يعني كان فيها تشؤوس كان في عدم صغار
بدات فجوه الثقه بين حمدتي وقاده الجيش
تتسع وبرزت حاله من عدم الرضا داخل القوات
المسلحه للتوسع نفوذ الدعم السريع اخذت
شكل تحرك عسكري للمره الاولى فيما عرف
بمحاوله الانقلاب الفاشله لسلاح المدرعات
في سبتمبر 2001 والتي اعقبها زياره
البرهان واحم التين معسكر المدرعات
وتاكيدهما ان الجيش والدعم السريع يعملان
معا وبتنسيق وثيق
[موسيقى]
هذه القوات المسلحه وقوات الدعم السريع
اصبح الدعم السريع قوه ضاربه هذا الامر
ازعج عدد من ضباط الجيش او وصولا الى
محاوله انغلاب فاشله ولكن عندما تطلع على
وقائع المحاكمه تجد ان السبب الرئيسي فيها
التوسع نفوز قوات الدعم السريع وحمته بلد
الصراع حتى مصطلح مكون عسكري ومكون مدني
بقى كانه انشغار داخل السلطه واثر على
الاعداء السلطه بالوقت تطور ده وصولا
للانقلاب انقلاب 25 اكتوبر
نفذ الجيش والدعم السريع انقلابا على
حكومه حمدوق واعلن البرهان حل مجلسي
السياده والوزراء غير انه اعاد تشكيل مجلس
السياده بالابقاء على العسكريين وممثل
اتفاقيه جوبا للسلام واخرج ممثلي قوى
الحريه والتغيير
واستبدلهم بمدنيين مستقلين
جميعا حافلات حل مجلس السياده الانتقالي
واعفاء اعضائه بضغوط داخليه وخارجيه عاد
حمدوك لمنصبه في نوفمبر 2021
عبر مسمى الاتفاق السياسي انني قد قررت ان
ارد اليكم امانتكم
واعلن لكم
استقالتي من منصب لكن حمدك استقال بعد اقل
من ثلاثه اشهر اثر حاله استقطاب وانقسام
في المشهد السياسي بين المكونات المدنيه
نفسها والمكون العسكري
متفقين في الانقلاب وشارك
بقواته وشارك بيت امينه
من اليوم
الثاني للانقلاب بدل بدل خلاف واضح بين
قوات الدعم السريع وقياده الجيش يعني باسم
والكلام ده عبر عنه يوم توقيع الاتفاق
الايطالي باعتزال رسمي عن الانقلاب
ادت الى ما حدث في 25 اكتوبر محمد حمدان
الايطالي ويعتبره هو حل
لندامته عن انقلاب 25 اكتوبر وذكر خطاب
مطلوب من حلفائه في المجلس المركز الجديد
انه حتى يتم القبول به يجب ان يعترف
ويعتذر عن الذي حدث وجزء منه برضو كان في
اطار
التنافس بينهم وبين البرهان
عدد الدعم السريعي جنحه للسياسه وجنحه
للتحالف مع مجموعه سياسيه معينه
والغرض الاساسي طبعا هو مش التحالف الا
السياسي ولكن الغرض الاساسي هو يعني تلبيه
طموحات خاصه وشخصيه جدا خاصه
الحاله السياسيه ساحه خلاف جديده بين
المكونين العسكريين حيث انحاز حمدتي
لمطالب ائتلاف الحريه والتغيير المجلس
المركزي في الدعوه لاتفاق ايطالي تم
التوقيع عليه في الخامس من ديسمبر 2022
لاداره المرحله الانتقاليه لمده عامين
ارتفاق الاطار ادى لشعال الصراع بين الجيش
الدعم السريع في قضيه اساسيه واحده او
قضيتين انه جعل انه الجيش والدعم السريع
يكونوا متوازيين او في كفه واحده رفض غاده
الدعم السريع الاندماج وضع شروط شروط كانت
تعجيزيه اكثر تمسك بعشر سنوات اصلا يعني
كم مناوره واضحه جدا وكانت مفضوحه جدا وهي
التي اكدت تواما عدم صفقه وعدم نيته في
دمج قواته في القوات المسلحه على ان
القوات دي هو اصلا كمصر على انها تكون
مستقله
كانت ورشه الاصلاح الامني والعسكري اخر
المحاولات السلميه للخروج بتوافق بين
المكونين العسكريين لتبدا ارهاصات
الاقتتال المسلحي بوتيره متسارعه دعم ورقه
في الورشه دي ورقه
منابسه المسكوت عنه اللي هو وضعيه الجيش
يعني الاصلاح في الجيش لابد انه الجيش ده
يكون خالي من اي انقماعات حزبيه اي ضابط
او اي شخص عنده انتماء حزبي المفروض يكون
خارج المؤسسه دي يكون جيش وطني
على مدى عشر سنوات واعلن انه يمكن ان
يوافق عن التنفي الالعاب من خلال ثلاث
مقترحات او التلات مطالب المطلب الاول في
حاله حوالي 800
ثم
اقاله وزير الداخليه ثم الموافقه على
انشاء قاعده جويه في منطقه السوق هي حاله
عدد 800
قبول الورشه للورقه دي ادى الانسحاب الجيش
من الورشه قبل التوصيات ومن هنا بدا
الصراع وبدا التخطيط لضرب الدعم السري بدا
الخلاف يتصاعد بين قاده الجيش السوداني من
جهه وقائد الدعم السريعي من جهه اخرى حيث
راى قاده الجيش ان حميتي يسعى الى اقصاء
القوات المسلحه والسيطره على السلطه من
خلال هذه المطالب اتضحت الاجنده التي يزعم
من خلاله تعديقك الدعم السريع وهو يزعم
الى انشاء جيش
واضح جنين انه عدم الرغبه في السير في
العمليه السياسيه في اللحظه دي
وضح جليا ان في حركه داخله الجيش حركه غير
طبيعيه وبدات التعبئه للحرب مع فشل
الوساطات وتفاقم حده الازمه حشد الدعم
السريع بدايه من فبراير 2023
قرابه الثلاثين الف مقاتل اضافي بجوار
قواته داخل الخرطوم في اخر اجتماع كان في
قصر الضيافه في حي المطار انا مشيت
للاجتماع كنت ساكنه في هذا الحي قبل
الانقلاب لما رجعت احضر الاجتماع كان
السكن عسكريه
وجود للدعم السريع
مبالغ فيه بدا يحسد في قواتي من مختلف
مناطق السودان داخل الخرطوم تمت زياده
كبيره جدا في كافه المعسكرات التي تتبع
للدعم السريع التي تنتشر في محيط العاصمه
الخرطوم كل هذه الاجراءات كانت تحضير لهذا
التمرد ثم بعد ذلك جاءت الخطوه الاخيره هي
تحريك ودون علم القوات المسلحه
الى منطقه مروي وفتاح الجويه طبعا في
استعدادات قبل فتره البرهان طلع دبابات في
الشارع ما اعرف طيارات درون بتصور مواقع
الدعم السريع يعني كانت واضح ان في اتجاه
للحرب
في الثالثه عشره من ابريل ارسل الدعم
السريع قواته الى محيط قاعده مروى الجويه
شمالي السودان ورفض طلب الجيش بسحب تلك
القوات كما رفض طلب الجيش باخضاع التحركات
قواته لاشراف الجيش
وتزداد مخاطره بقيام قياده قوات الدعم
السريع بتحشيد القوات والانفتاح داخل كل
تصرفاتهم يعني كانت
للاستقلاليه وكانحري على انهم يكونوا
مستقلين تماما بقواتهم القوات المسلحه
وحتى التنسيق المطلوب لعمليات المطلوب في
الاونه الاخيره اصبحوا ما يتغيروا بهم
في الرابع عشر من ابريل فشلت الوساطات في
تقريب وجهات النظر بين الجيش والدعم
السريع وشكلت قياده الجيش خليه ازمه
معتبره الدعم السريعه وحدات عسكريه متمرده
يجب مواجهتها
وبهذه المخالفات يعتبر تمرد على اوقات
المسلحه ولكن رغم ذلك صورت عليه قوات
المسلحه وكانت تزعزع لمعالجه الازمه
بالحوار
حدد اجتماع المفروض يكون يوم السبت الساعه
9:00 صباحا
الساعه 9:00 صباحا يوم السبت بعديها
الساعه 11 المفروض يكون في اجتماع عام بين
كل الغور واقعه على الاتفاق الايطالي ومع
قاعده الجيش وقاعده الدعم السريع
لتفادي الحرب ولوضع الرؤيه للسير في
العمليه السياسيه
بين الجيش وقوه الدعم السريع الميداني
مفاجئ بين 15 من ابريل 2023
افاقت الخرطوم على وقع مواجهات بين قوات
الجيش والدعم السريع لتبدا فصول صرعا دامن
ما يزيد من التهديدات المتعلقه بوحده
السودان في مواجهه تبدو وجوديه لكلا
الفريقين
[موسيقى]
هذا وتبادل الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع
الاتهامات بالمسؤوليه عن بدء القتال اولا
واحتدمت المعارك في الخرطوم وفي مناطق
اخرى في البلاد رغم دعوات القوه المدنيه
السودانيه والامم المتحده والاتحاد
الافريقي ودول عديده منها الولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا لوقف اطلاق النار كما
تعددت المبادرات لتسويه الازمه ومنذ ذلك
الحين شهد السودان تطورات عده منها اصدار
قرار من القائد العام للجيش ورئيس مجلس
السياده الفريق اول عبد الفتاح البرهان في
السابع عشر من ابريل الماضي بحل ميليشيا
الدعم السريع واعلانها قوه متمرده على
الدوله اذا وصرح قائد الدعم السريع اكثر
من مره بان قواته تقاتل من وصفهم
بالمتطرفين وتضحي من اجل الشعب السوداني
والتحول الديمقراطي على حد تعبيره جرى
الاعلان عن هدى بواسطه امريكيه وسعوديه
لكن هذه الهدى لوقف القتال بدءا من لكن لم
يتم الالتزام باي منها كان لافتا تصريح
الممثله الخاص للامم المتحده
فولترز في الخامس من مايو الماضي بان من
دعاهم الباحثين عن الثوره ينضمون الى
القتال مشيرا الى مسلحين من مالي وتشاد
والنيجر في جده وفي السادس من مايو الماضي
بدات محادثات ترعرعها السعوديه والولايات
المتحده بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
لكنها وبعد خمسه ايام لم تصفر الا عن
اتفاق الجانبين على السماح للمساعدات
الانسانيه المطلوبه بشكل عاجل بالوصول الى
المناطق المتضرره من الحرب مع الالتزام
بضمان حمايه المدنيين في التاسع عشر من
مايو قرر قائد الجيش رئيس مجلس السياده
اعفاء محمد حمدان دقلو قائد الدعم السريع
من منصب نائب رئيس مجلس السياده وعين في
الموقع نفسه مالك عقار توالت الهدى ولم تت
وقف الانتهاكات وهدد البرهان اواخر الشهر
الماضي باستخدام ما دعاها القوه المميته
ضد قوه الدعم السريع وقد بلغ عدد النازحين
نتيجه هذه المعارك اكثر من مليوني شخص في
مختلف انحاء السودان كما فر نحو 600 الف
سوداني الى دول
[موسيقى]
نرحب بكم مشاهدينا الكرام وفي انتظار
يبدو ان ضيفينا الكريمين باتا معنا نرحب
بضيفي الكريمين من ميسوري الدكتور عبد
الله علي ابراهيم المفكر والمؤرخ
الاكاديمي السوداني الذي وصل والتحق بنا
للتو من باريس الدكتور اسماعيل احمد رحمه
الباحث القانوني والمحلل السياسي السوداني
اهلا بضيفينا الكريمين لعلنا نبدا معك
دكتور عبد الله نتمنى ان تكون قد التقطت
انفاسك اي توصيف لهذا الصراع الحاصل الان
والدائر الان في السودان السودان الذي عرف
الكثير من الصراعات والنزاعات منذ
استقلاله
هذا الصراح
يعني ثمره
حكم
ظل منذ 1956
لا يحظى في كثير من الاحوال
يعني علاقه
نسيقه او علاقه رشيقه ما بين ما بين الشعب
والحكومه لانه انفقنا في منذ استغلالنا
يعني معظم الوقت تحت ديكتاتوريات وتحت
الديكتاتوريات منسوبه الى
الشمال او
النيلي او العروبي او الاسلامي
في علاقه غير يعني غير صحيه
ونشا من هذا تزمر مشروع من الهامش اتخذ
ادوات مختلفه
يعني انتهى في الاخر الى انه لا يمكن حل
اي مساله بغير الرفع السلاح
داء ادى الى كلما نحن فيه بما فيه انه هذه
الحكومات
الديكتاتوريه
وتجسدت اخيرا في نظام عمر البشير استعان
بالهامش نفسه لكي يقمع الهامش
الثمره بتاعته هي الدعم السريع
فاصبحنا يعني اصبحت اصبح الحكم يعني
بين هذه الكتل
وفيه رفع السلاح يعني يعني اللغه والمجاز
السائد هو رفع السلاح لا يمكن لاي قضيه ان
تحل بغير بغير سلاح ووضعت هذه
التكتيك المسلح كما اسميه وضع القوات
المسلحه التي اراد البشير تهميشها بشكل ما
وضعها في هذا الوطن الصعب
بما فيها انها نفس القوات المسلحه نفسها
ارتضت لنفسها ان تكون يعني
[موسيقى]
جزءا من النظم العسكريه التي تتعلق ففي
ضلال جاري في المركز الضلال انه في قوه
مدنيه حديثه هي القوات المسلحه اسلمت
نفسها لنظم ديكتاتوريه ومن الجانب الاخر
فيها مش اسلم نفسه لتكتيك الحرب المسلحه
فغابت هنا كليه غابت الثقافه وقابه
المعرفه وقابه التاريخ وقاب التجييش
الاجتماعي
النقاب
الشعبي العمل الاجتماعي العمل الواعي
لتغيير ما بنا فاصبح اما ان تغيرته
بدكتاتوريه من داخل الثقونات الجيش او ان
تغيرته من هامش او بمساومات مختلفه ما بين
الاثنين
من الجانب الاخر يجب ان ندخل انه هذه
الحركه التي اتكلم عنها هي الحركه الشعبيه
دي عبرت عن نفسها في ثلاث مرات عن ارادتها
في ثوره 1964 وفي ثوره 1985 وفي ثوره
ديسمبر اعطت مؤشر وطريق واضح لانه الاشياء
يمكن ان تحسم بغير سلاح وبطريق سلمي ثلاث
مرات كان الهامش يرفع السلاح في الجنوب
وفي دارفور وفي غيرهما ولا يبلغ من مطلبه
شيئا
وانما الذي يبلغ المطلب ويحل المساله
ويزيل النظام الديكتاتوري ويفتح الاثار
لمناقشه حول القضيه السودانيه وحل الازمه
السودانيه كانت هذه المقاومه الشعبيه
السلميه لا يستطيع ايا ممن حمل السلاح
وخرجوا به في سماء العاصمه وفي سماء
دارفور سابقا وفي الجنينه وفي اي موضع
يستطيع ان يقول انه ازاله
عاهه في الحكم المركزي ما ازالوها وهم
محرجين حيال الحركه الشعبيه التي دائما ما
فتحت الباب امامه يا اخواننا المساله لا
تحتاج الى كل هذا السلاح وهذا التجيش وهذه
البغضاء تحتاج تعالوا الى كلمه كما تقول
لكنك يعني رسمت الواقع بان ما يحدث الان
هو لغه السلاح رفع السلاح دعني اتحول
للدكتور اسماعيل ونتساءل حقيقه
عن وجهه نظره في هذا الموضوع والذي يحدث
الان كيف يمكن توصيفه نائب رئيس المجلس
السيادي مالك عقار قال بان ما يجري في
السودان هو تمرد وليس حربا اهليه اضافه
لما سمعناه من الدكتور عبد الله نواد ان
نسمع وجهه نظرك كيف تصف ما يحدث اليوم في
السودان
طيب في البدايه انا استاذن الجزيره
واستمعها بان اتقدم باحر التعازي للاهل في
ولايه غربي دارفور مدينه الجنينه المنكوبه
والتي شكلت ماساه انسانيه اروع وافزع من
مجاز الرواندا وتحياتي وتقديري للشعب
السوداني الصابر وتحياتي وتقديري
لاستاذنا الجليل عبد الله ابراهيم
وتحياتي وتقديري للاستاذه فيروز من
استدعاءات الجزيره
اولا السودان اقرب دوله في العالم انها
تتاكل من الاطراف وانا شبهتها بمريض
السكري الذي تبطر على اطرافه الى ان يسكن
القلب والدماغ ويعلن الموت ما يجري الان
هو عباره عن معارك وحروب كانت في الاطراف
ووصلت الى القلب والضماق في وسط الخرطوم
العاصمه
طبيعه الصراع في السودان
هنالك وجه حقيقي مسكود عنه وهو صراع
اجتماعي عنصري من البدايه بتاع التكوين
الدوله السودانيه التي انتهت بعض سقوط
دوله المهديه بعد سقوط دوله المهديه هي
كان عباره عن سقوط الاعلان صراع
اجتماعي
وعنصري مغلف بعمل
سياسي كما اشار الدكتور استاذنا الجليل
ان
الهامش يعني يتمرد او
بعلن مطالبه بالسلاح لكن على العكس تماما
من 56
شاهدنا الدوله المركزيه في السودان
تستخدم القمع ضد اي يعني محاولات للتعبير
عن الحقوق اي جهه حاولت تعبر عن مطالبه
وعن حقوقها بتم قمعه وقصفها وضربه
بالطيران والى ان انتقلت هذه العاهه
المتهوره من القوى العسكريه الى وسط
الخرطوم
ما يدور الان في حقيقه هي معارك معارك بين
قوتان مسلحتين في العاصمه وهذه المعاريخ
خالفت قواعد الاشتباك وقواعد حرب المدن
ولذلك استخدمت فيها
اسلحه وقصف طيران شكل انتهاك واضح
للامن والسلم الدوليان وحقوق المدنيين
العزل في حد ذاتها اوقعت جرائم تشكل
مسؤوليه
امام المحكمه الدوليه هنا جرائم ضد
الانسان وجرائم حرب ولكن حقيقه الصراع
الان الذي يدور في السودان هو صراع تمرحل
منذ تاسيس الدوله السودانيه اللي بدت
بدوله 56 او ما يعرف بدوله تركه الاستعمار
بالنسبه لافنديه مؤتمر الخريجين ولذلك
كمرحله المساله دي الى انفجرت اليوم في في
الخرطوم تعبير صادق في ان الصراع اجتماعي
عنصري باد وات مختلفه ادوات سياسيه ادوات
عسكريه ادوات حزبيه وغيرها
وداء التوصيف الحقيقي لما يجري في السودان
الان من صراع اما ما يدور ما بين الجمرلين
البرهان
وحميته هو اكمل هذه الجزئيه ما يدور الان
ما بين الجنرلين برهان وحماتي هو يعني
صوره تبقى الاصل لما بدا في الصومال
بين محمد عيديد وعلي ما حد لما
حاولوا اي واحد يفرض نفوذه ويسيطر على
تركه الحكم الديكتاتوري بتاع سياد بري
والان بعد 30 سنه ظهرت قوتين عسكريتين
تحاول تفرض نفوذها للسيطره على تركه
النظام البائده الديكتاتوري الذي رحل
من الان اود ان اعود للدكتور عبد الله وكل
واحد فيكم يعني قدم وجهه نظره
نظر تشريحيه لما يحدث الان ايا كان الذي
يحدث سميته الدكتور عبد الله رفع للسلاح
دكتور
اسماعيل ايضا شخصه من وجهه نظره لابد ان
نعرف مدى تاثيره الان على تماسك الدوله
تماسك الدوله السودانيه احتمالات الدخول
قوه اخرى داخليه ايضا في هذا الصراع الذي
امتد جغرافيا ايضا الى مناطق اخرى كيف
تراه
يعني في كل هذه في في يعني في هذا الزحام
الذي نراه يعني يجب ان نتعقل كثيرا
ويعني
من ينظر الى هذا الصراع كانه بين الجنرلين
انا افتكر يعني يكون غد ابعد النجعه او
انه في الطريق الضال نحن الان بين مؤسستين
مؤسسه القوات المسلحه
ومؤسسه
مؤسسه ميليشيا
لا لا يعنيط واحد في حلقه ويقول لي بما
لكن طلعت من الجيش
والجيش هو الذي رعرعها اي حصل حصل ولكن
هذا لبن مسكوب
وتبقى الحقيقه في انه في حاجه اسمها
القوات المسلحه كجزء من الدوله الحديثه
وانت لا يستفي حل من اعتبار ما سينتهي
اليه هذا الصراع في قوام الدوله السودانيه
وقوام الدوله السودانيه
رهين بمؤسسات حديثه
ما اذا انتصرت الميليشيا دي انا سالت
كثيرا جدا ما صورتكم عنها في اليوم التالي
في اليوم التالي لها ماذا ستقول عنها كيف
ستحللها وجيشك انتهى
في السودان يقول لك يعني
انا بين المر والذي امر منه المر
هذا هو الجيش الذي يعني ضل بنا خلال عقود
في احكام وفي نظم
مستبده قارعناها واحده بعد الاخرى
واسقطناها واحده بعد الاخرى
وما بين الامر الذي لا نعرف عنه شيئا نحكم
بواسطه ميليشيا
وحكم الميليشيات عندكم في لبنان في ليبيا
في في وهي ظاهره مش ظاهره في السودان وفي
وفي روسيا الان
هذه هذا لا يمت باي شيء السبب الى الدوله
الحديثه فنحن ما عندنا طرفين عندنا طرف
واحد
لاستمراريه ما يعرف بالسودان بغير ذلك انت
اخترت الامر ونحن نشتري انا اختار المر
واختار مش مر اختار علقم لانه انا مش صغير
وانا لما خرجت في مظاهرات ضد النظم
العسكريه ما كانوا الناس زادتهم عندهم
تعريف للدول نظم العسكريه منذ عهد عبود
والى السكنات يا عبود صغار وفي الجامعات
فده هذا هذا هو الطول لذلك لما اسمع انه
هناك طرفان وان هناك جنرالان انا بفتكر دي
بدايه
الارتباك ودي بدايه الحلول الضاله
ان يتمسك السوداء
واضح دكتور عبد الله اسماعيل واود ان اسمع
وجهه نظري في هذه النقطه اذا دكتور عبد
الله يرى انه من الاجحاف الحديث عن طرفين
وبالفعل البرهان على حل
هذه الميليشيا واعتبرها متمرده بالاحرى
والسؤال هل يمكن ان يكون حميدتي وقواته مع
شريكا في اي تحول مدني وتاسيس ديمقراطيه
راسخه في البلاد ووجهه النظر حوله هي كذلك
ومن قبل يعني شرائح كبيره ايضا في السودان
هو بقد النظر عن التوصيف ما هي حقيقه
الاشياء مع احترام لدكتور استاذنا ولكن
هنالك كتله اجتماعيه اصطفت خلف قياده
تدعى البرهان جنرال في الجيش وكتله سياسيه
اصطفت خلفه وهنالك كتله سياسيه
اصطفت خلف الجنرال يدعى حمادي وهنالك كتله
اجتماعيه والاثنين عندهم كتل عسكريه يعني
اشخاص حاملين للسلاح الان اللغه الموجوده
هي لغه السلاح ولغه المعارك ولغه الاشتباك
ده الماشي يعني فنحن لسه ما وصلنا للنتائج
اذا كان هل اذا انتصر برهان او اذا انتصر
متصارعه في الدوله مع غياب
الشعب السوداني ودور
الشعب السوداني صاحب الحق الاصيل في في
هاي المساله فانا في تقديري
هو واحد من الاتنين اما
الجنرلين يزح من المشهد السياسي ويخطفه
وبالتالي الشعب السوداني ككتله اجتماعيه
متوحده كتله سياسيه تقدم مبادره وطنيه
لانه الدوله السودانيه تولد من جديد لقدام
واما واحد ينتصر على الاخر
وحتتحول المعارك الى حرب طويله الامد
عندنا نموذج في جنوب السودان وانتهب
الانفصال عندنا نماذج مستمر لعشرين سنه في
دارفور وفي النيل الازرق وغيرها
فانا في تقديري هذه حقيقه الاشياء وهذه
حقيقه المعارك الان تدور يعني الدكتور عبد
الله دعني اتحول نعم
حقيقه الان نسمع الكثير من المبادرات
ونسمع ايضا احاديث من داخل السودان وزاره
الخارجيه مثلا قالت ان التوصل للتسويه
المطلوبه في البلاد وشان داخلي يفترض ان
يترك للسودانيين بعيدا عن التدخلات
الدوليه هل السودان فعلا الان بعيد عن
تدخلات الدوليه ام ان قضيتها وقد دولت
بالفعل ونحن نسمع عن تدخل اطراف عديده
سواء بمبادرات او باقتراحات
والله انا يعني بهتم بالله ماله الاخ يعني
نحن اين اين نحن من كل هذا وانا حينما
استمع الى ما يعني ما يقال عننا في العالم
بفتكر انهم ما فاهميننا يعني لا انا انا
غير يعني لا
اسمع من العالم وهذا العالم يعني خلينا
اديك مثل انا امبارح بقرا حاجه عن الصحراء
الصحراء الغربيه والنزاع الذي دام فيها
لمده نصف فقر ماذا فعل العالم لها
حتى الان هي قضيه مجمده وهي قضيه بتاع
التقارير ومجلس الامن ينعقد نحن في
السودان عندنا ملكه اسمها ملكه التغيير
وكما عدت لك ما استسلمنا ابدا انت من وجهه
نظرك انه هو شان داخلي والحل سيكون داخليا
ويجب ان يكون داخليا
وكلامي هذا وكلامي هذا هو مناشد
للناس ان ينتبهوا الى ان الى ملكاتهم يعني
مثلا
لماذا في كل حسابات
يعني مثلا الدعم السريع او حركات المسلحه
لماذا يسقطون اراده الشعب السوداني في
ثلاثه ثورات ان يغير ما بالمركز المركز
الذي يشتكون منه ده والذي يعني يعتقدون
انه لن ينكسر الا بحد السلاح لماذا لماذا
لا يعتبر لا يعتبر
الفضاءات التي فتحتها تلك هذه الثوره هذه
الثورات مرارا وتكرارا انا كنت في ثوره
اكتوبر 19
واول شيء عملته في ثوره اكتوبر عقدت مؤتمر
مائده مستديره لمناقشه قضيه الجنوب ودعت
لها افارقه وامم متحده
وكذلك الحال في خمسه وثمانين انا بفتكر
زملائنا في الهامش دخلوا في التكتيك
المسلح
بغير النظر وبغير تدبر
منذ البدايه بان سائد الان هو لغه السلاح
في ظل هذه اللغه ايه مخارج باعتقادك بقيت
السودان
يخرج يا ستي الاراده السودانيه التي نريد
لها ان تتشكل وتنتهي الى حل اولا ايقاف
خرج السلاح ماذا الى ماذا ادى خرج السلاح
بالجنوب انفصل وعنده حركه شعبيه وعنده
رمزيه اسمها جراند وعنده حاجه اسمها
السودان الجديد الى ماذا انتهى خرج السلاح
الى يومنا الراهن الى ماذا انتهى الوضع في
دارفور خرج السلاح عبد الواحد قاعد في
حركه عبد الواحد في جوبا ومني
والحركات التانيه صالحت واخرى غير لم
تصالح
استصحاب السلاح هو غرور
وهو يعني يعطي حامل نوع من العصمه
وانا دائما اكرر لهم قول املكار كابرال
انتم اذا حتى لو حملتم السلاح انتم
مناضلون تحملون السلاح انتم السياسيون
تحملون السلع انتم ليست عصبه تحمل السلع
وكانوا عصبا
وفي الجنوب كانوا عصب والان في دار في
جبال النوبه هم عصب مسلحه لا علاقه لهم في
كثير من الاحوال بالانسان العادي الذي كان
يسخر في ثوراتنا في 64 في 65 تجد الجمهره
عمال مزارعين طلاب افنديه مثقفين
اذا كانت في اراده سودانيه الان
تستدعى وتستجمع الى حل تستجمع على
ازاحه السلاح واضح واضح جدا يعني هذه وجهه
نظرك ضروره ازاحه السلاح الحل ان السؤال
الان الدكتور اسماعيل يعني في انتظار ان
يزاح هذا السلاح حاملوا هذا السلاح يدعون
الان الى مباحثات يعني جرت مباحثات في جده
ولا زالت يبدو ان هناك اطراف ترعاها
نتساءل حقيقه يعني
باعتقادك هذه المبادرات هل يمكن ان تنجح
ايا كانت الاطراف التي ترعاها سواء
مباحثات جدا للتراث السعوديه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ام حتى المبادرات التي
نسمع الان عنها في افريقيا من قبل دول
افريقيا
عزيزتي فيروز المبادرات لن تنجح بعد
اندلاع المعارك في السودان وانا عشيرته
انه هذه المعارك او التي تعود الى حرب
طويله الامد مؤجله من العام 56 هذه الحرب
كثير من السودانيين ولو الاستاذه استاذنا
الجليل كان صادق صارم مع اسف لو بقى صادق
معي انه هذه الحرب نحن كسودانيين لخلينا
نعترف انه اصلا في دواخلنا مؤجله من 56
واتى اليوم انه تنفجر هذه الحرب ومن قليل
ومن قبل شويه اشار استاذنا الجليل الى
ادانا واضحه للمؤسسه العسكريه فان هي
بتحاول تركز على الناس البطال بالحقوق
بالسلاح فانفصل الجنوب بتحاول تركع الناس
في دارفور النيل الازرق وغيره والان
المساله مستمره والان كذلك نشاهد هذه
المساله الان لن تنجح اين القوه الوطنيه
السياسيه اين هي الان الان قتال بين
مؤسستين عسكريتين وبين جنرانيني وفي تاثير
داخلي وتاثير خارجي التاثير الداخلي في
مجموعه من الكتله الاجتماعيه بنهج عنصري
ونهج ايدولوجي اصطفت خلف البرهان على اساس
ان كتائب جهاديه كذا كذا واضحه سقوط
الاحتياط المركزي كشف كل شيء وهنالك كتله
اجتماعيه في الهامش وحمل السلاح وغيره
وغيره اصطفت خلف الجنرال
ابعاد واضحه رؤيه واضحه
بالتالي حتى اكمل هذه الجزئيه التاثيرات
الدوليه التاثيرات الدوليه حاضره الاخت
فيروز الاداره الامريكيه حتى الان واضح
جليا انها تترك الجمارك
اضعف للاسف وقت انتهى انتهى تماما اشكرك
جزيل الشكر دكتور اسماعيل احمد رحمه
الباحث القانوني والمحل السياسي السوداني
كنت معنا من باريس كما اشكر جزيل الشكر
دكتور عبد الله علي ابراهيم المفكر
والمؤرخ والاكاديمي السوداني كان معنا من
ميسوري موضوع طبعا يستحق اكثر من حلقه
للنقاش حتما سنعود اليه وكل امنياتنا
لاخوتنا في السودان بالسلام والامان ختام
حلقتنا السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]